thorough left
we can right jaw the elbow coming in is
very weak you can't elbow like this your
elbow have to be locked body in line
whole body turn lock so that way you can
control it more whole body movement my
name is master wong i've been training
on wing chun training for about 35 years
and i train in beginning in uk and then
i train in china as well today i'm going
to look at some wing chun movie and clip
and see how real they are
that's a good move that definitely
knocked somebody out now onto the wing
chun side you punch like this vertical
punch like this so you can punch like
this or you can punch straight like this
but that one there you see him using
more traditional kung fu so stand up and
turn at that punch create a lot of power
wing chun is specifically using a lot of
fast hand it's a very close quarter
combat news
this movement here is a very new nick
observable wing chun using that as well
upper elbow but this one here you see
the full body weight come in attacking
the silver plate this one is perfect to
be used you see a lot of this movement
in real life elbow using for close
quarter because a lot of time elbows
very very heavy structure the most
strong structure in the body is elbow
head knee this is a heavy movement there
that you got to be able to defend thing
a lot of time when you're doing wing
chun you do fight three or four people
move behind your fast hand here like
bruce lee when you see them is it wing
chun
it's the element of it that element you
are moving element of it but for me to
use it i instead of hitting like back
hand on the face when using the job to
the float because in real life that will
do a lot more damage
if you're using wing chun this movement
here he won't jumping around a lot cause
everything is wider you know when it
traditional body wider movement wider so
it's more for power use wing chun more
closer like you see that don't move very
much just stay in the area so on the bus
here in the wing chun size that's what
wing chun designed for it's designed for
close quarter combat so mixture a little
bit of wing chun a lot of them a
traditional martial art for realism i
think i'll give them five because you
can't use them like that the way he
deals in on here for the real life
donnie yan playing this character of yet
man yid man is a real person catching
bruce lee bruce lee uh master
if the ten kratika up one wing chun guy
i think ten karate person eat the wing
chun person alive choose them up and
spit them out crafty people trying very
different karate using a long distance
kicking punching long range wing chun
use close range when you get inside the
range of the karate karate person cannot
use a weapon it will limit down but if
the in the range the crutchy person can
use in a long range like leg kicking to
able to defeat that
in wing chun you don't really do a lot
of high kick up above the waist but in
this scenario he used quite a few high
kick you're using if you like it good
enough not all the time you need to kick
below the waist but in combat like this
it's good to kick below the waist
instead of up
as you can see some of the movements are
hit under grab controls and kick that's
what they do they try to broken the
person arm and kick the limb that's what
the quenching is and breaks them down
why they come down he controls them a
little bit more closer where he is to
attack because he don't want the enemy
to everywhere
you sit there and watching him he said
why isn't people standing there waiting
for their turn if i'm in real life my
friend getting beat up at the
outstanding hold on is it my turn yet no
i won't give him a chance to elbow my
feet to the back but this is this is a
movie
classic windshield wrap them control
them move them shoot them as soon as you
show them somebody come along you move
them other side you move them where you
want them and then you can deal with
more than one person
that kind of one thousand while his slow
motion falling down for you to keep
bombastic it's good for movie reality
term no tracing after him you might fall
over same time while we're doing this
kind of movement in body
not grounded enough because you're all
balanced you're not standing up you're
moving forward all you need to do the
karate guy kick up on his butt and he
fall over it'd have to be ground and
control because when you're high they're
low when they're low they've got more
strength now sometimes you ask yourself
why are you down there to one thousand
punch somebody face is it over to it yes
it's overdoing it i think the biggest
myth movie show about wing chun on the
uh fighting side they portray that wing
chun need to do thousand different moves
before somebody get hurt in real life
should be one hit one kill for the movie
side is good in real life it's not that
great so i just say around about seven
out ten
classic wing chun movement on there it's
like ready to fight you know
in wing chun
and soft you need to be able to blend
them when your opponent's soft you need
to be hot because then you're able to
defend them so the attack committed
heart you need to be soft to deflect
them
that's a very classic wing chun movement
as well so you got choice when you're
working this kind of movement there if
the fan you control them if they fall
you just squeeze
broken one part finish if you're in a
fight and somebody certainly grabs you
the best thing to do chop your chin like
this because you deflect and then
step back that will be attacking the
joint then it loses then from there
using your body you could rip the hand
and then you continue your attack
who's got the upper hand now
or hidden there because your arm like
this where you scream you don't able to
go any energy and then because you don't
energy you can't break out but he just
sweep off because he's the god he can't
able to perform like that how you get
out of this movement there so in a wing
jung style you see a lot of movement
like this you flick your muscle flexing
your wing so he can't grapple with you
if i flick like this my hand will become
inside and i will grab her behind i will
give him fuel elbow to the face fill it
with his body and i'll give them the
kick to get rid of him so on this one
here i like the cartoon it's interesting
in
reality tell me some of the movement you
can use and someone you can't use i will
give this movie here about four
first distract target
then block his blind jab i like this
kind of movie because all the time
martial is the same using your mind to
fall first before you're doing it
because mind tell your body what to do
come with cross to left cheek
attacking to the temple is a very good
classic wing chun puncture i like that
but the attacking temple is a little bit
harder to able to hit because it's small
if you move like this it miss really
attacking right along here it's a lot
more better
late
attacking into the eho classic classic
so that's why he do this way boom so he
can't hear anything anymore for me to
using this movement instead of talking
like this i will boom straight drop to
the neck cutting the blood supply to
your brain you're out finished
employ elbow block
the way he doing it look in there weaker
because you don't see the whole body
movement but you're using your body the
whole body deflect that's called a
tensile you're moving to using that to
diverse with the hand while you're
diverting the movement when the hand out
of the way your body structure diverts
in the force so the heavy coming in you
don't need to very much you go like this
that force will go this way
and body shot
move like this straight up classic
boxing movement wing chun using that yes
but don't move the way they move like
more like classic boxing the wing to
more like teal on the side bit more and
come up using tom q that's where the
second level of the wing chunk using a
lot of punching now use attack a lot of
organ ribcage here flow area so that's a
very classic uh movement
left the movement there the hand coming
in a little bit weak if you apply this
if it drops that will land your ribcage
yes that might lamps your elbow but you
got to make sure the wing block the
block on the hand you need to chop the
hand right down to able to cover your
length of the ribcage otherwise solid
hormone going to get broken ribcage we
can right draw now elbow coming in is
very weak you can't elbow like this
doesn't get any power doesn't matter how
good you are your elbow have to be
locked body inline whole body turn lock
so that way you can control it more
whole body movement
kick the diaphragm
this part here he'll keep coming in
classic wing chun because the idea is
long solid like the punch solid like the
elbow solid for me to using this kind of
movement in this situation i wouldn't
want to use in heel kick you have to be
able to move right into reach to get the
heel kick because your whole
leg will be straight like this to be
able to kick like that it's hard to use
reality team is the point kick coming in
directly your toe pointed into the
diaphragm onto the silver plaque that
would do the same damage even worse for
robert downey jr he'd been training on a
wing chun for a while is it able to
execute the movement well now if i say
not good they're not going to be nice
and if you say good that i lied to
myself i say average out of 10 i think
i'll keep this about four
now this is a very very classic wing
chun yellow compared to hollywood stuff
they're very different you don't cc move
a lot so the classic wing chun is you
don't move around a lot you're using
your hand defending your vision of a 300
degree
[Music]
so this whole thing here as a fun uh
thing me i see moving i don't want to
mess up the
the bean cook and why the tomato bean
curd bean curd is very soft that's so
how
elegant the wing chun is because these
are about a woman that's why she called
wing chun
wing chun she developed this system out
for her to use doesn't matter how strong
you are she can using her relaxed and
movement to defeating the big and strong
opponent
this is very classic there elbow and all
this movement here this is a
go into
wooden dummy when you're watching the
wooden dummy you're using a lot of this
hand here elbow coming in um turn all
this elbow stuff is all the time so the
body attack elbow elbow elbow attacking
elbow defending all this macho is very
good at demonstrating the movement i
will give this one 8 out of 10.
this movement here you can see it very
classic now this is sick and hardpoint
pole training for the wing chun one of
the two weapon that wing chun use this
is what the wing chun people use instead
of trying on weight a lot then using
that to train
they hold like that because they're
using it for spear
move like whipping twisting attacking
freaking the only second half movement
on this and then mix them up together
with the hand foam on the footwork so
you bring the power onto the post
is it really necessary two persons using
the same thing now reality term is two
persons using same movement more likely
both of them get cut up this is the
traditional wing chun butterfly knife
and sword that's why wing chun use long
and short weapon when the enemy have
short weapon you're using long weapon
a lot of the movement there as you see
the wing chun movement using hand
movement like a tan attacking they are
transfer them into the weapon but onto
the weapon for this to be used you're
getting the idea of illustrate the hand
form and then now you got a weapon
attached into your body here so you can
able to move well to using it
okay stop that there that's pop like
could a bucket for nine chi sao instead
of using hand then using a knife instead
controlling the force coming in hot and
soul see the classic what i told you
about in wing chun hot and soft you're
using to moving your energy from your
opponent there
when you get close the weapon it can be
used and use the elbow and then using
knife when you got a distance because
you gotta need a distance to able to use
in it when they're closing up that's
when you use elbow head knee and also
using shoulder a lot as well
then using the classic chain punch
company idea is when you punch somebody
wants a block but you want it bam they
can't block like this so more than
likely if they do 20 punch they're going
to land on your face once what you're
going to use to block it using either
wing block or using packs out to block
of this chain punch
classic beauty beauty finger strike
attacking the eye attacking the flow
attacking a vulnerable spot emergency
news when you get to this level of
beauty you've become very dangerous to
your opponent so gotta be very careful
how you're using it
instead of seeing he feel now
mostly use a lot of one inch punch boom
boom boom when you attack you feel them
first then follow up on the second and
then use your waist but when you punch
them when you they are tense tent
next movement you hit them they start ah
when they start to ah then the nice one
bang then forcing the energy pass it
that's how you knock them out overall
for choreographers very very good the
way they do them just showcase a very
truthfully little bit of wing chun how
you use it on the scene i give them
about eight to nine out of ten
this is a wing chun moment the movement
on there that is coming in attacking
defending but is he winching movement
here is it more traditional side no more
wing chun fit into him chit kundo that's
why he needs a lot of high kick what
bruce lee believing in what you take it
news for reject what did newslett so he
very disgot a lot of traditional stuff
that no functional to him
that's another classic one this is the
time kill movement coming in on break
boom gone break coming in on break so
that's what he said sooner coming hand
breaking the arm control breaking the
leg side kick of the wing chun low kick
on there to hurting the joint bigger to
the lower leg there very classic yeah
what he joined the demonstration there
is in the wing chun side we find in a
closed ring we don't need space but what
just knowledge needs space because you
use a lot of kick bruce lee he don't
need space now when you get close he
don't use any high kick now he's using
low kick i have to give this 10 out of
10 because he's my idol
this is more like carly
carly movement than more like wing chun
but wing chun do that as well you're
using this code drill this kind of drill
is helping you to get the sensitivity
when you put that knife on the person
you see how much power they put into
your arm how you respond
again people to understand that true is
the dual you need a thousand repetition
to be able to respond you need to drill
that into your system when something
happen in real life fight you can't
think you either feel or see before it
happen so the whole idea of learning
this is learn about feel learn about
sleep where you place your hand where
you put your hand how you put your hand
because all the knife and hand is very
fast good
this one here is not really attack this
is really a drill when somebody put a
knife at you two things you need to
realign if you're in a situation that
you got nowhere to go you have to make
sure you're looking for weapon make sure
you're starting something you can use to
able to defend that quickly think fast
and looking for the exit to run to get
out of the way don't stay in front of it
because you cannot defend them know
yourself know your enemy know your
ability and know your surroundings i'll
probably give them a 5 out of 10. i like
liquor's k2 in the movie pretty serious
good actors my favorite wing chun movie
at all time is the portugal sun with the
chocolate loaded into the history of
wing chun where they come from in bill
doing the movement apply them into the
screen and making the screen for wing
chun very beautiful the way it done and
uh summer whole when he's using it he's
using
wing chun in the realistic life head
elbow everything all the power the body
can apply into the wing chun to make the
wing chun functional for him thank you
for watching if you enjoyed this movie
here click on the movie above